[Musique]
m'appelle julien j'ai 36 ans
j'exerce le métier de sellier garnisseur
un métier d'art depuis quinze ans je me
suis détourner de la politique parce que
je ne connaissais pas mes idées mes
opinions dans les discours de chacun de
chaque partie malgré la désinformation
sur l'importance et le mécanisme de
l'europe
je me suis intéressé quand même j'ai
écouté les discours de chacun parti je
me suis arrêté sur le discours de
monsieur bel ami dans lequel je me suis
reconnue nous avons besoin de faire des
choix courageux en europe face à la
crise économique
nous avons besoin de sortir de cette
naïveté coupable naïveté de la france en
europe
naïveté de l'europe dans le monde nous
avons besoin de défendre de nouveau nos
entreprises nos emplois parce que nous
sommes européens
nous voulons écrire notre histoire les
républicains sont les seuls à avoir des
propositions concrètes et c'est pour ça
que le 26 mai j'irai voter pour les
républicains
[Musique]